I love you yeah
[Music]
remember myself
following
us about it because
um
[Music]
go ahead
um
[Music]
thank you
I don't know
[Music]
um
Facebook .com
[Music]
good evening everyone
hold on we got a few settling down still
I know I know this whole thing
hi everybody uh welcome to the table my
name is Abby Salzman
um I see a lot of new faces which is
awesome so
um yes yes uh we have two announcements
tonight and they pertain to next weekend
um the first of those is the state of
the table which is next Sunday after the
service we do this twice yearly and we
basically go over our leadership
transitions finances goals and where
we're headed as a community for the
church as a whole so anybody is welcome
to attend that and that's going to be
after the service next Sunday night in
addition the other announcement pertains
the next Sunday service as well we have
a guest speaker uh Sally Gary is going
to be guest speaking she's the founder
of centerpiece and a long time friend of
the table so if you would we would love
to see you and support Sally and as well
as just attending the service that you
think
um
I don't know about you it's been a busy
weekend for myself so I've been really
looking forward to just taking a minute
here at the service tonight just
just kind of settling in a little bit I
was listening to Mindy and before
um and Jesse before they were killing it
so I'm very excited for the worship set
tonight
um so if you would uh just take a minute
uh take a deep breath and just look
forward to the great service that we
have ahead
[Music]
um
you guys I just had one of those magic
bars that Don made in the pack and I
usually try to save the bars for like
visitors and stuff and because I'm about
to sing and you know you don't want to
like coat your throat and all that junk
but that was unbelievably magical so if
there are any left back there I highly
suggest you getting one and then look up
Don's Bakery online and order some
because those were incredible thank you
Don
um if I'm spitting during the songs
though that's why I I abandoned all my
principles and went for the Magic Bar
we are really glad that you guys are
here and it's great to see new faces um
do you guys want to stand up with us and
I'm just gonna pray real quick as we get
started tonight and we're gonna sing
father's house so
um Jesus thank you for this time
together thank you for community and for
um gathering with
um like minds and different minds and
all of us with all our different stories
and our uniquenesses and
um what we bring here to the table God
we just lay it out in front of you and
ask that our time together would be
meaningful that we would interact with
your spirit and feel your presence here
as we sing
in your name
[Music]
's on this journey I get lost in my
mistakes what looks to me like weakness
is canvas for your strength my story
isn't over my story's just begun I feel
you want to find me that's just what my
father does
feel you want to find me that's what my
your bird is down
here in the father's house take a shame
at the door here they welcome anymore
[Music]
rival's not the end game the Journey's
Where You Are
you ever want it perfect you just wanted
my heart and the story isn't over if the
story isn't good
failures never
finals
failures never find when the father's in
the room
oh
mother's house check your shame at the
door sitting welcome anymore
the father's house
[Music]
prodigals come home
the help please find hope love is
breaking through when the father's in
the room
prison doors fling wide the Dead comes
to life Love Is On The Move when the
father's in the room
Miracles take place
cynical Find
Faith love is breaking through when the
father's in the room
Jericho walls are freaking
long holds now we're shaken love is
breaking through when the father's in
the room
is breaking through where the father's
in the room
only your lay your burdens down
Father's House check your shame at the
door silly welcome anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
all right nice guys
kiddos you guys are dismissed to go to
your classrooms if this is your first
time here with new kids then we have
um
through uh six years in this room right
here I believe it's Kinder through six
years or four through six right here
right yeah is that right yes through
first grade through first grade and my
mind like spaced out totally I'm like
what age does go in there and then our
older kids go over here um through sixth
grade and babies are in that back
hallway if you have a young toddler or a
baby with you
um
all right
um we are going to transition into the
prayers of the people and if this is
your first time with us it's an
opportunity for us to lift up the things
that we are carrying into this space
before God and before one another and
allow us to hold up those burdens
together
um believing that he is here and and he
wants to carry them with us and
alongside of us so we're going to read
this prayer aloud together if you will
and then we'll leave some space for you
to share a name or a situation that's
heavy on your heart and then we'll close
the prayer out together again at the end
and if you're online please feel free to
leave your requests in the comments and
we will read those together
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
thank you
Jaden Angelina
[Music]
Jacob
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
amen
[Music]
as a rise
strength of God
go before
Lift Me Up
as a way
Eyes Of God look
upon be myself
[Music]
[Laughter]
as a way
heart of God
satisfied
[Music]
as a he
voice of God
lead me on
my God
[Music]
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me above and below me before and
behind me in every item sees me Christ
be all around me
[Music]
all around me
there's a ghost
hands of God
by my side
as a race
Breath of God
Fall Apart
bring me peace
[Music]
leave Christ be all around me
oh
Christ be all around me
[Music]
all around me
foreign
[Music]
forever
Lord
[Music]
above and below me before and behind
everything
[Music]
Christ be all around me
before and behind me in every Island
[Music]
Christ be your world
Jesus
Precious Jesus
[Music]
foreign
oh for Grace
to trust
him more
[Music]
we're going to learn a new song it's
called you hold it all and um I just
wanted to
let you guys know kind of where my
head's been at as I've been learning
this song and planning it for this set
um one of the things that I feel like
can be sometimes difficult to capture in
worship music is
um being able to incorporate
um and merge our everyday life and all
of the Practical nitty-gritty day-to-day
grinds with this other spiritual aspect
where we're stopping and pausing and
reflecting and being introspective and
and trying to acknowledge the spiritual
aspect of our life and sometimes trying
to make those two things feel congruent
and feel like there's cohesion there can
be a challenge for me so we go through
you know Monday to Saturday just grind
grind grind grind grind and then there's
this moment on Sunday where it's like oh
let's stop and worship and get into our
feelings
and then we go back to the grand grand
and what I've really appreciated about
this song and this album is the way that
it has married our everyday life and The
Human Experience that we all share with
our worship and with our spiritual lives
with who we are in Christ and who he's
called us to be and how he's called us
to live and acknowledging that both of
those are tied together they are they
should be Inseparable they I mean in
actuality We Are Spiritual Beings going
about these day-to-day tasks and so I
just invite you as you listen to this
song and perhaps hear it for the first
time
um as you sing these words make space
for God to meet you not in just the
spiritual aspect of your life but in the
holistic life that you live
um bring him into that as well in this
space
[Music]
thank you
God we bring you the work of our hands
and now lay it down lay it at your feet
what we've done what we've built what
we've broken
lay it down lay it at your feet
you hold it all Jesus you hold it oh
[Applause]
[Music]
where it hurts weird hands we can bodies
lay down lay it at your feet
what we've used what we've lost what
we've wasted lay you down lay it at your
feet
you hold it all Jesus you hold it all
you hold it all oh Jesus you hold it
[Music]
all our dreams all our plans are
Ambitions lay you down lay it at your
feet
and even if nothing comes to fruition
lay it down
your feet
lay it down lay it in
this God
we bring our whole selves every hurt
every happiness
our Brokenness and our wholeness
[Music]
God we bring it before you knowing that
you are a part of every breath
you're a part of every task every word
every relationship
God would we integrate you in
the way that you truly want to be a part
of our moments
a part of each day
and God would we recognize
that sometimes we're missing the mark
but even there you are holding us
you are calling us forward
calling us higher
[Music]
would we trust that voice and would we
follow it God
thank you for your unconditional love
thank you for your constants
you're anchoring
[Music]
your presence
that does not leave us or forsake us
[Music]
help us to ground ourselves into that
we love you Jesus and we thank you for
this time together
amen
would you guys turn and greet the people
around you say hello and then Brett will
get us started on our message
well Grace and peace good to be with you
all
so good my name is Brett and uh yeah
just it's a joy to be with you and to
welcome all of you and as always that
includes those join us online love you
all Lots you're not forgotten and
um especially anyone here who is new
um we're really really glad that you're
you're among us
um and yeah I hope you feel a sense of
welcome and I don't know people have all
sorts of feelings coming into a church
space
um but boy I think if any any space
should feel welcoming it should be a
church
it that you know
churches don't always feel that way but
they should so I I certainly hope
um that you can you can sense that so um
we are
in a series right now it's titled the
Book of James and we've just been kind
of unpacking major themes and insights
from this
um marvelous book uh from the New
Testament and this is actually like the
theories finale the the final message
um next week as Abby mentioned we'll
have Sally Gary here who for those who
don't know like he is um I know some of
you like oh Sally and others are like
who's that um so Sally she's sort of
like a I don't know like a spiritual mom
to this community
um she has been doing work trying to
bridge the gap between the lgbtq
community and the church he was raised
Church of Christ
um has wrote A Few Memoirs and books
about her experience and so she's been
trying to bridge these communities
trying to um reach out to
um Christians who find themselves in the
lgbtq community often without a sense of
support she's been doing this for like
15 17 years I mean it's it's been a
while like way before churches like the
table were popping up you know like I
mean this is she's been doing this work
a long time so um not only will she be
here just hearing her story which I
think can really connect with anyone
who's ever felt a little bit out of
place in church whether you know gay
straight or otherwise
um but also she'll be sharing a little
bit about her organization what what
they have going on and I I can see in
future years probably us partnering with
centerpiece more and more
um because that's the nonprofit that she
runs and they've just they're doing such
good work and so um at any rate that'll
be
um all next week so big big week next
week is when we have to stay at the
table afterwards and and all that like
their Church our little church family
business meeting
um so it'll be yeah I think a really
really good Sunday so um this week
though the title of the message is
confession
confession and uh I know that word that
can be a loaded word right honestly this
verse can be a little bit loaded because
it starts off talking about Sin and such
you know
um and I really want to try to re kind
of reframe our imaginations around this
to where it's not some sort of I don't
know heavy-handed you know
thou sins you know and um there's just
so often so much like kind of uh
words like judgment condemnation
shame all sort of come to mind and I I
want to try to
shift out of that mode and into some new
territory with this word like let's
reimagine this word and um not that we
just entirely like think of it
completely utterly different but but
that we can get some new connotations
around in a way that I hope is
um life-giving and maybe some words like
genuine and vulnerability and
authenticity
you know like that's what I'm imagining
so um but I don't want to pillage my
whole sermon so all right we'll get into
it so
um we're gonna this is just one verse
just a short short little passage
although we'll kind of read it in
sections tonight so we'll kind of unfold
so the first part of James chapter 5
verse 16 begins this way
therefore confess your sins to each
other
so we'll call this step one confession
and the way I want to frame this is to
say that a a lack of confession
is in essence a flight from reality
itself
um and in other words
I think we kind of get in a rut where
it's sort of like well I want to be a
good person and a good person doesn't
have to confess that there's the
confessors and then there's hopefully me
and then of course this ties back in
with the shame then what we stumble and
fall or messed up or whatever and then
we're like oh no now I'm in the
Confessor group but I can't stand to be
that so I'll pretend everything's fine
everything's fine I'm good you know what
this ends up is
um a church of of Pretenders you know
Community is everyone's pretending I'm
fine how are you doing fine fine never
better everything's great just great you
know it's like we're all dying inside
you know instead of
um just being real
like we're all struggling
ever I mean isn't that remarkable like
we all come to the church all feeling
like we're the only one
it's like oh the irony of this
um so it's a it's actually a flight from
reality
um it's a flight from myself it's a
flight from community and thus from
Christ
um but but to confess that's like the
great return
um to myself to community to Christ and
to just reality itself
um
you know I think of course it's quite
tempting to live in denial I guess
um which is maybe why we do it it's
because you know confession takes so
much courage
so much vulnerability so much you know
all those words I was naming earlier
like to be real and honest it's sort of
like it isn't just plain's scary isn't
it you're just plain scary uh it is it's
difficult this is why I say often I long
for not just the table but like Ultra I
just long for church to be more like an
AAA meeting
I do I um and not necessarily in the
sense of like you know like literally we
all just need to get in circles right
here and you know no more music and
worship you know but I'm talking more of
like the um not just the little Sunday
service but I mean like
just the whole culture
you know there's a culture in AAA
um of confession but it's not kind of
like oh my oh are you here to confess oh
well we don't have anything to confess
ever you know no it's sort of like yeah
you're here
because of course like this is you know
everyone's struggling everyone's limping
everyone's you know I mean my goodness
especially in our culture is there
anyone who's not addicted to something
I mean he's everyone just sort of
skating through life like no prob you
know like probably not oh
so no I think we need to kind of
normalize this in in the sense not not
in the way of just being like Oh it's
fine we're all addicted let's just
continue you're not in that way but in
the way of like Hey we're all here
together we're just together and we're
just doing our best and can we just get
real for a minute you know like that's
that's kind of what I mean the the
beauty of
a is that kind of
um that kind of honesty and
vulnerability and
um
I think you know I was thinking why is
it though the church is so tempted to
um kind of pretend why are we so tempted
to pretend here and I think
um it's at least in part because really
not just church but religious
communities in general
um tend to be places where there are
standards you know there's like
even Society in a way looks to churches
into religion to provide the very kind
of roots of like how to live what is
right and what is wrong you know what
will the boundaries be like
and you can see it and I don't think
that's like so the answer is throw every
standard out you know I don't know if
that's the thing because I think I mean
we can't really live life human beings
can't flourish as individuals I don't
think communities can flourish without
there's some boundaries there's some
like hey this is what it's like when I'm
flourishing and I can kind of tune into
things that I do and I'm not flourishing
you know it becomes clear
um
so we don't need to throw this out but
you can see where the the shadow side of
that
right and that's this is what happens is
because we say well here's the bar you
know here's the standard here's the
expectation here let's be loving and
let's be kind and let's be honest and
let's be you know we kind of set the
standard but then what happens like we
don't reach the standard
and then we're like
I'll just pretend I reached the standard
you know and this is where um we might
to kind of sum it up might say that our
own standards drive us Underground
our own striving for Perfection ends up
weirdly pushing us
to hide
and so I do I think there's a certain
wisdom
in where James is coming from here it
kind of nudging us to confess as uh step
five in Alcoholics Anonymous says
admitted to God to oneself and to
another human being the exact nature of
our wrongs you might say that uh
confession is like
the opposite
of whatever we're doing on social media
whatever is going on there
confession is sort of like Now's the
Time where I don't do that
right in essence if social media is
our most curated
filtered
airbrushed
self
you know just like
everything's great and it's always great
I'm just winning you know
um if that's if that's social media
confession is not that
it's it's us at our like most dejected
kind of like oh my gosh I am a human oh
so human
snot nose you know like just it's it's a
like that's that's confession
um there's a movie that I I like um I
like a lot it's the Spanglish it's kind
of older one with like Adam Sandler and
such um yeah lots of good good stuff in
that one and uh if you've seen it
there's
um the character played by the actress
Tio Leone it's just sort of one of the
she's like the kind of the mother in
this family film and
um she's just not like in a good
headspace for a variety of reasons she's
sort of like a I don't know this sort of
image of like a mother whose children
are starting to grow up She had a
business but it kind of failed and then
the kids you know she knows like it's
probably five years and everyone's out
of the house and she's struggling with
like identity and insecurity and all
sorts of things so she her kind of mode
um
is to kind of project is sort of to put
her social media best self forward all
the time so she is like eating all the
perfect food and she's like working out
you know at least once if not seems like
twice a day and there's scenes where she
has these I don't know how Tea Leoni can
do this stuff like crazy yoga poses not
like you know downward dog or whatever I
mean like the hard stuff you know and
she's just like it's
like it's crazy she is and on it
and she's pushed push her kids to
succeed though you can kind of tell it's
sort of about her feeling good about
herself as they succeed you know it's
sort of it's getting a little murky you
know and that the insecurity it's
bubbling over in her relationship so
it's almost like to the external world
she is a great success you know but like
on the inside she's just not at peace
you know just not at peace and her
relationships with the people she loves
the most aren't aren't doing well and
this she ends up kind of filling this
void this insecurity by like going
outside the bounds of her marriage and
so there's this scene where
um it's been eating her up inside the
the guilt the shame like all the things
you know and so she needs to confess so
she sits down there I I still have this
image of the scene it's great she's
sitting on the bed with her mother
who she wants to confess to first and so
she's there on the bed and it's just a
sea of kleenexes around her just an
ocean and she is she is not knows she's
eyes puffy
and she's just kind of poured out her
heart to her mom
and her mom says you you know you need
to tell your husband she's like I know
and she kind of gets up the courage and
she goes
she stands up off the bed she's like how
do I look
and of course if you've seen the movie
she looks horrible like it's not a good
moment you know and uh but I love her
mom's response her mom says
you look genuine
you can use genuine
and I think that in many ways that's
like the turning point for her
genuine
you can use genuine I I think that's
what James is inviting us into
you know not not beating ourselves and
I'm the worst and you don't know but
just just genuine
just genuine here's me here's me and and
all of you know the the greatness and
the my gifts and The Wonder of it all
and and in the crap you know just messed
up in this and the struggle and the pain
and the it's not even just about Sin
either right it can be just in my
suffering and my loss and my just
disappointment I mean anyone ever just
reached a point in your life where
you're just like I just feel
disappointed with how my life is turning
out he
um like this was not the plan I had the
plan there was a plan what happened to
the plan you know
um
if not church
if not here
where can we be real
um
so I think that's that's like the
invitation that James is inviting us
into into genuineness into vulnerability
back to reality so that's step one but
of course the process um it doesn't end
there James continues therefore he says
confess your sins to each other
and pray for each other
we'll call this step two prayer
the act of prayer and I'm thinking
specifically in the context right of
confession
um is Grace
and blessing
it's a reminder of who I truly am sacred
and who in Christ I am becoming
you know what the world could use more
of
Grace
and blessing
you know what the church is uniquely
called to offer people
Grace say it with me and blessing right
like this is and yet this is the irony
right coming back to our irony of all
ironies so often the church is known for
precisely the opposite judgment and
condemnation you know
fear and shame you know just like oh my
how
how why
of course that's not who Christ was like
Christ just moved to the world and it
was just so much grace and blessing and
when he had harsh words it was often not
for The Outsiders the religious
Outsiders it was like for the it was
people like me honestly pastors he was
very dumb on pastors and religious
leaders and such that's who he was and
mostly because we weren't offering Grace
and blessing that was kind of the
critique that he would bring it was
often like you're loading terribly heavy
burdens on people's backs you're like
what are you doing you know um if he got
worked up it was often along those lines
so here I think we have such a beautiful
like what a beautiful opportunity in
calling like we get to move through the
world ourselves
here we follow the lord Jesus Christ
offering Grace
following his example I mean just
remember there he is on the cross
and what does he say in that moment
father
forgive them
they do not know what they are doing
talk about a radical Grace and
forgiveness
here we follow our Lord Jesus Christ who
moved to the world
offering blessing I mean I just think of
all the prayers and all of the
um the way Jesus used his hands
to to hold to touch to hug to heal to
bless
I mean these were not hands of violence
these are not hands of anger for Christ
no it was just this beautiful extension
of blessing in fact I was reading I was
um curious like what are the moments
um where Jesus like literally not just
sort of metaphorically but like
literally offered a blessing and I was
thumbing through the scriptures and I
came across actually I don't know how
I'd never seen this it's the very end
like we're talking the final verses of
the Gospel of Luke Luke chapter 24
um it ends this way so this is verse 50.
so he's there with the disciples like
this is like final moments on earth when
he had led them out to the vicinity of
Bethany he lifted up his hands
and he blessed them
and while he was blessing them
he left them and was taken up into
heaven
how did I never catch this before
Christ's final act at least on earth
like in the flesh now it's through the
spirit in his body of Christ right but
like in the flesh here his the last
thing notice was in a Thurman was like
all right a few things to remember guys
you know like well his Thurman wasn't a
prayer it wasn't even like a miracle
like let me leave with some Pizzazz no
just a blessing
a blessing
uh you can do this
you've God's grace is on you God's call
is on you God's favor is with you you
are sacred and holy and beautiful like
Jesus Final Act literally extending
blessing and I was thinking like
I think this is so powerful because sin
is sort of the opposite like sin often
causes us our own kind of messed upness
and you know falling short of what we
feel is the standard can lead to like a
feeling of like Brokenness and and
um I don't know like shame and like
we're somehow dirty or something
and there's something in that the Active
touch of extending and receiving Grace
and blessing that's like the opposite of
that like if we've been sort of weighed
down and brought low so to speak that
extension of Grace and blessing does
what
it just like raises us up doesn't it
just moves us up you see to bless
another
uh or to bless is to remind another of
their sacredness
to bless is to remind another of their
sacredness words of blessing speak to
your sacredness speak to your to your
holy origin your Creation in the very
womb of God
and to your sacred calling
like God knows you and loves you and is
calling you and drawing you into love
itself into a life of love
and like that's the invitation so when
we extend that blessing like that's in
essence what we're doing we're not that
we're imparting it or giving it to
someone like aha through me now you have
the favor of God you're welcome you know
not that but it's um it's an
acknowledgment of it
there's a marvelous novel
uh I'm a very big fan of the writer
Marilyn Robinson
he's a very slow novel so they're not
for everyone if you're like a fan of I
don't know
John Grisham you won't like this novel
but um it's but she's it's actually kind
of like a Trilogy I think maybe she
might have written another one now I'm
trying to count them up but it's just
marvelous and um she wrote this novel
it's it's written uh it's titled Gilead
and it's written kind of in the form of
this like extended letter where this
aging
um congregationalist Minister named John
Ames
he got married very late in life he was
like a bachelor like his whole life then
got married right at the end and he had
this young son
but uh so his his son now is like seven
years old but he knows that like he's
not he's he's not going to be long for
this world so he wants to you know kind
of leave something that his young son
can remember of him so he's just writing
letter after letter after letter in his
kind of final months and so that's like
the novel is mostly these letters
and uh there's this marvelous little
moment where he's recounting a story
from his own childhood
and uh he of course was like raised in
this well I'll read you the quote this
is uh
they did kind of a strange thing so he
says this it occurred or sorry now this
might seem a trivial thing he writes to
his son to mention considering the
gravity of the subject but I truly don't
feel it is we were very Pious children
from Pious households in a fairly pious
town
and this affected our Behavior
considerably once we baptized a litter
of cats
foreign
it occurred to one of the girls to
swaddle them up in a doll's dress there
was only one dress which was just as
well since the cats could hardly
tolerate a moment in it they would have
had to been unsettled as soon as they
were cursed in any case I myself
moistened their brows repeating the full
trinitarian formula I was glad to hear
they didn't dunk them that's better you
know just they were there weren't
dunkers that's not their tradition in
the name of the father and the son in
the Holy Spirit
their Grim old crooked tail mother found
us baptizing Away by the creek began
carrying her babies off by the nape of
their necks we lost track of which was
which
but we were fairly sure that some of the
poor creatures had been born away still
in the darkness of of paganism
and that worried us the great deal
I still remember how those warm little
brows
felt under the palm of my hand everyone
has petted a cat but to touch one like
that with the pure intention of blessing
it
is a very different thing
it stays the mind for years we would
wonder what from a cosmic Viewpoint we
had done to them it still seems to me to
be a real question there is a reality in
blessing
it doesn't enhance sacredness
but it acknowledges it
and there is power
in that
I love that Insight if it's not it's not
um giving it it's not offering it right
like you again your whole sacred origin
in calling you are all you already have
the favor in blessing of God you already
Are Holy Holy Holy sacred precious a
child of the Living God like you already
have that
but but blessing
Grace
touch
it acknowledges it it names it and when
you pair that
when it's following
a genuine authentic vulnerable
confession
like y'all
that is that is not just of this world
that that is something divine
something to find
so this leads us to the third part
James writes therefore confess your sins
to each other
and pray for each other
so that you may be healed
step three healing
you see I am no isolated person
pursuing salvation alone no matter how
much Americans think that it just isn't
the case God has determined that my own
healing is bound up with others
forgiving and being forgiven
knowing and being known I think the
great danger of American Life
is isolation this is the shadow side of
our strict individualism
we it's like we know people without
really knowing them you know the guy in
the cubicle next to us the fellow mother
of you know the kid on the basketball
team or whatever you know like we know
people
Without Really knowing them and without
feeling known by them
and yet here we are in church and so
what's the invitation
it's to a greater authenticity it's it's
too confession it's to Grace and
blessing and forgiveness it's to True
community
but to do that right we got to open up
and and start to recognize oh
I can't do this all on my own
there's a marvelous quote my friend uh
Jamie Holderman who he
um they moved to uh Arizona but
uh Jamie we're chatting this week and
they suggested this quote and I was like
oh my gosh I'm putting that in my sermon
and it's from uh it's from Nadia Bolt's
Weber a former Lutheran pastor and
writer and uh Nadia's great she's great
and um I would say this is sort of like
her life message almost this whole theme
of being real you know if you know
anything about Nadia she's like super
real and
so before I read the quote I want a name
it's interesting James doesn't say
therefore confess your sins to the Lord
uh and then he shall forgive you you
know or something uh it's confessions to
each other
and I was reflecting on why that might
be and I think that's what Nadia speaks
to she says while I might feel inspired
by someone who is good I only feel less
alone when someone shares their failures
with me
the things they struggle with the parts
of themselves this is the key part that
are more Jagged than smooth
it just so happens that the jagged edges
of our Humanity
are what actually connect us to one
another
the image she gave around this was when
we do not confess when we hold everyone
kind of arms length even though we
pretend we don't you know but we do
um it's like we're too smooth to connect
we just Glide right on by you can be
here Sunday after Sunday and just kind
of Glide right on by
but but when we show our own Jagged
edges when we're real
these become precisely the places of
connection
our healing is bound up with confession
to one another of the jagged edges that
we all have
so
my prayer for each of you is
whether it's in a meet up which if
you're not in Meetup highly suggest your
meetups but however it happens for you
my prayer is for True community
people in your life that you can show
your Jagged edges to
Beyond just your partner too even that's
important
but we often just kind of do the little
nuclear family thing you know
um
and
that from that you begin to thrive
that you begin to learn of your own
sacredness and that a deep deep healing
would begin in you in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit amen
so as we uh as we come to the table of
the Lord tonight I think it's a pretty a
fairly easy connection
um
we come as people in need
you know again not in a shame and
condemnation way but as just
who we are just human beings in need of
confession in need of Grace
in need of blessing in need of a
reminder of Our Own sacredness
in need of God
and so as we partake of the body of
Christ in the bread the blood of Christ
and the wine
prayer is that this would be a moment of
healing and connection for each and
every one of you so the way we'll do
this is we'll um just kind of start here
in the front and we'll just work our way
row by row we practice what's called an
open table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
want to participate then you are
absolutely free to do that there's
something new that wants to connect with
the Risen Christ then you just come
forward regardless of like you know do I
am I in the right denomination or
whatever just you just come forward if
you want to and having said that there's
no Stigma if you're not in a place where
you want to do that that's fine
um you can you can stay seated
um the red is wine the white is grape
juice
and uh finally you can just partake
whenever you'd like you could take
immediately you can return to your seat
maybe say a prayer and then partake but
no one will like lead you through the
exact you know moment of of taking the
elements so this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow
and you who have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
foreign
[Music]
we're going to close out with that song
that we learned earlier and um
to integrate these words into into our
week as we kind of prepare for Monday
and what's ahead
I just wanted to read a couple lines
real quick that have stood out to me
this week in the spirit of confession
it says what we've done what we've built
what we've broken
what we've used what we've lost what
we've wasted
I just love naming those things because
we are people who build up and we are
people who tear down sometimes and we
are people who can create and share love
and we are also people who hurt and
injure we are people who can be wasteful
and let's just go into our week naming
those things and holding them before God
and believing that he is The God Who
holds it all who has room and capacity
to love us even the midst of our
confession in the midst of our mess he
is calling us forward so will you guys
close out with us and sing this along
just kind of as a prayer sending us into
our week
they're welcome to stand
[Music]
s lay it down lay it at your feet
oh well we've done what we've built what
we've broken lay it down lay it at your
feet
you hold it all
Jesus you hold
it all
[Music]
where it hurts weary hands we can bodies
lay you down lay it down your feet what
we've used what we've lost or we've
wasted lay it down lay it in your feet
you
did
all Jesus you hold
it all
you hold it all Jesus
[Music]
all our dreams all our plans are
ambition
lay it down later your feet
and even if nothing comes
[Music]
at your feet
please
[Music]
I needed that I don't know about you but
laying it down and laying it out our
feet is such a good reminder
um I don't know I'm a planner by nature
and it is just not within me sometimes
to just turn it over so it is a good
reminder
um if you are new this is your first
time we've all been there at some point
there's a small little table as you head
out the door please fill out your
information we'd like to get to know you
one of our leadership team members will
reach out to you we really do want you
to be a part of the table
um
if you need a blessing if you are having
a hard time if you have anything going
on it doesn't even have to be hard it
could just be something I am here again
my name is Abby
please grab me I am willing to talk to
you I want to talk to you and pray with
you
um I know we all need that at some point
we are a community built out of
generosity if that's within you again
there's a small little box on the way
out we would love your donations or you
can go to thetabletx.org I want to send
you off with a blessing which is kind of
great because Brett was just talking how
wonderful blessings are so if you would
I know most of you are standing at this
point if you want to put your hands out
in a posture of receiving that's
something that I took as I joined the
table it took me a little bit to get
there
send you out with this benediction
you are a child of God
you are a child of God this is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day so as you go into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you are and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with be blessed and I hope
you all have a great week
[Music]
foreign
you hold it oh Jesus you
hold it
oh
you oh Jesus
[Music]
foreign